it's really all about computing it's all
about speed how much of this really vast
universe how many of the 400 billion
stars in our Milky Way galaxy can we
explore looking for someone else's
technology and today the tools I use are
14 orders of magnitude 14 factors of 10
better than Frank Drake was able to use
in 1960 and that improvement is going to
continue and continue at a faster and
faster pace because our computing
capabilities are improving exponentially
and for anyone who's ever studied an
exponent things double and then they
double again and that doesn't seem very
much but after you get through a number
of doublings in fact you're making
changes at an enormous rate so
everything kind of happens at the end we
recently built a brand new telescope to
do SETI and radio astronomy all the time
and simultaneously and with that
telescope in the next 10 years we expect
to be able to observe at least a million
stars maybe 10 million stars over a
wider range of frequencies simply
because the compute power is there and
it's getting better every day
well what we're looking for with our
radio telescope is a signal that doesn't
look like the kinds of signals that
nature produces so when natural sources
of emission like pulsars or molecular
clouds or hydrogen gas emit radio
signals they spread it across the
spectrum they they sometimes it's
relatively limited sometimes it's
completely broadband but we have the
ability with our technology to create a
radio signal that's a single tone a
single channel on the radio dial if you
wish and it's very detectable against
the background noise if you have the
right detectors so that's what we've
been looking for something that's
obviously engineered something that
nature at least as far as we know can't
produce now that may be the wrong thing
we might have guessed wrong we might as
we get more computational capability we
might be able to look for other kinds of
signals that occupy more of the spectrum
but still appear different than the
signals that natural sources amit so if
you can imagine a two dimensional screen
and it's full of snow and static like an
old analog television set right which
wasn't getting good reception but on
that two-dimensional display imagine a
line that's drawn and it can be straight
up and down or it can be slanted and if
that screen is displaying two dimensions
one a frequency and one of
time that line would be a signal at a
single frequency and if it was straight
up and down that frequency would be
constant if the line has a slant to it
the frequency is changing in time and
that might well happen because the
transmitter is accelerating with respect
to the earth we're also now beginning to
look in the optical part of the spectrum
not just the radio and where's in the
radio we look for frequency compression
we look for narrow signals in the
optical what we're looking for is time
compression we're looking for really
bright flashes that lasts a nanosecond
or less now as far as we know again
that's the kind of thing that nature
can't do but with the right detectors
even when you're looking directly at a
star you can see a bunch of photons
showing up in a single nanosecond
against the background and if you found
such a thing it would certainly suggest
a technology an engineered signal
well on earth we currently leak a lot of
signals broadcast television for example
radio the signals are intended for our
local neighborhoods but in fact many of
those signals go on beyond the earth and
travel and spread out in a bubble around
the earth that gets bigger one light
year per year so we're announcing our
presence inadvertently that's going to
change in the future as we change our
means of broadcast technology and go to
direct TV kinds of deliveries and
digital but actually even the satellites
that are delivering the signals have
some leakage out the back side of them
so we'll never go completely radio quiet
but we're not actually deliberately
transmitting signals to different
planets we now know about 455 planets
around other stars so we are now
beginning to know about some of the
places we might decide to transmit to
but we're not doing that and the reason
is we're actually too young right we're
a very young technology in a very old
galaxy so with respect to interstellar
communication we've had appropriate
technology from maybe a hundred years
the galaxies 10 billion years old so we
don't know whether there are any other
technologies out there but we do know
that we're the youngest that could
participate in interstellar
communication anyone younger than we are
with less technical capabilities and we
have can't yet be part of a conversation
and the odds are in a 10 billion year
old galaxy that anyone elses technology
is a lot older than ours
so right now it seems to to me that it's
appropriate to let the older technology
do the heavy lifting so transmitting is
harder than receiving so we'll put that
job on them and then if we ourselves get
to be an old technology if we grow up if
we in fact cannot get ourselves
organized to be able to take on projects
that last not two years or five years
but ten thousand years or a hundred
thousand years which is really you need
to do if you're thinking about
transmitting purposefully then when
we're older it would be appropriate for
us to begin to transmit and of course by
then I hope that we could answer the
question about who should speak for
Earth and and what should they say